playing 20 or 25 games but he's played
in all 13 games in March he's back right
down the middle downhill and a slam I'm
spectacular view to bounce past a good
finish to defenders there but LeBron
says better have three or four there
well Lance and LeBron a scintillating
passing this split Williams was a foul
underneath by the way Koosman kcp eight
out of 13 for 21 points not McCann right
now that Caruso goes all the way to the
rim of Iraq it's going to be taken
offense only by Caruso so they reset at
the 14 Teresa over Julius Randle Alex
Caruso has double digits here the
Florida is second from long range
and Julius Randle gave him too much
space Clark now in double figures eight
out of the last 11 switches dime and
right back at you yeah if you're gonna
foul you got a wrap-up it's nice to live
here actually
it almost looked like Ken Rogers at the
last second trying to get out of the way
there was contact though gives the
Lakers their biggest lead of 12
so you mentioned it man another giveaway
Caruso adding to a big start to the
second half for him gives the Lakers
their biggest lead of 12
so you mentioned it another giveaway
Caruso adding to a big start to the
second half for him he gives it to
Caruso into the attacking 47 Brousseau
tough shot no problem for him tonight we
keep telling his team they keep going
I guess they checked with the sleep
specialist 35 seconds left
[Music]
sneaking right in brother like he went
to what the suitors follow JaVale McGee
us the timeline leaves it were the
rookie from Gonzaga and optic
caldwell-pope spouse and Caruso with the
left hand wanted to make sure that what
this deadly ejected a bad pass stone
stayed up near way too long attack on
the rod open ball ball pulp he's got
four in a day score now there's some
pressure on the funders did you see yeah
turns the corner Steven Adams rotates
slowly and swipes in Caruso says yes I
have hops oh look at that focus in add
six points nine rebounds and nine
assists with a couple of blocks Tuesday
against an outside
caldwell-pope undrafted employing at
Duke and the G League and has worked his
way up inside one Cruz
nice assist gold of theta is still
getting his basis and still working into
conditions but very close right now
ready certainly for the playoffs
Caruso fakes the shot can they get the
two team in the West magic number for
Golden State is three Rondo three
[Applause]
cousin's Caruso came off the weak side
and puts in the gym he is one of seven
oh that's my tech just a moment he gave
everybody a jolt take a break then take
you to the American Express halftime
report radio here with John Ireland
doing radio broadcasters versus sugary
always clever what Kyle insight by
Caruso no Ron Clippers this is a
separation I'm talking about let's see
if they can keep it going Caruso al
Mulaney go
working driving get the shop a lot
muscala with the rejection to the
cutters the drive in the store in the
jam but Jonathan William there's no way
the Lakers aren't going to play hard you
have to match that let's run away go
through so let's run away cuz we're so
same group out there for the Clippers
picked up the intensity on the defensive
end
the new by Wallace Dylan got the foul
five risotto the Texas AMM
he had a career high 23 in a recent
brand caldwell-pope I ran with him at
least to finish that play and he had the
double Caruso Williams trying to go to
sleep
turnovers are even at 12 apiece that
have to bury Chivas Ginza for the most
part knock it down
the moose Heyliger friendly they're
still have to go on the third that's the
shot clock
come the Lakers attend the Scala Rondo
step-back mid-range hits the hill
rebounded Jones guru so three got it
Alex Caruso a new career-high who is
that guy I just kept it Caruso the
offensive rebound by jamario Jones and
Caruso no hesitation what's the roses
been an all-star miscommunication by the
Clipper so he has 30 if this kid crowded
stays with it picked up by temple on the
switch rival ago
is he in also or what Wow 37 minutes
last night